e aí
[Música]
g1
e obrigado olá tudo bem
eu posso começar com uma pergunta
e quem aqui não está com smartphone
a ninguém
e olha vou dizer para vocês
a todos nós estamos vivendo no presente
tem gente lá fora que com certeza não
está usando o smartphone e eles estão no
futuro e nós temos que procurar essas
pessoas para perguntar o que mais vai
acontecer no futuro
é porque nós estamos agarrados uma
realidade presente em que o smartphone
faz parte total 100 porcento na nossa
vida e a gente dificilmente acredita
quando alguém fala para você isso vai
acabar isso vai mudar vamos curtir um
pouco sobre isso vamos falar sobre o
futuro e para falar sobre o futuro né
porque apresentação minha fazer
rapidamente eu sou professor eu sou
também pesquisador na área de inovação e
tecnologia eu gosto muito de estudar
sobre como a tecnologia caminha como é
que ela avança eu sou também escritor de
alguns livros é das longo da vivo na
área de tecnologia também ao longo da
vida eu fui desenvolvendo a minha
adoração por tecnologia também somente
eu falei tecnologia assim um minuto
fazer umas 10 vezes então eu sou meio
nerd né sou um hacker também porque eu
não me conformo com muita coisa que eu
vejo dentro e fora da tecnologia e as
uma característica hacker e eu sou
futurista recentemente
e acrescentei essa função a minha vida
então por ser recente eu sou futurista
treine ainda
bom e o que é ser futurista se futurista
é você ter acesso ao esotérico você ter
poderes sobrenaturais na verdade não se
futurista é que sobre conexões conexões
com o quê com além não também não as
conexões que a gente fala sobre
futurismo são conexões que ligam você
estudar o passado entender como é que
passado nos trouxe até o presente e
possivelmente descrever os cenários a
partir dessa trajetória cenários de
futuro então ser futurista não é achar
que as coisas vão acontecer é estudar o
caminho do avanço científico tecnológico
e contentar a partir disso estabelecer
cenários futuros então essa é a minha
função atual e vamos falar sobre um
passado bem recente o início do
smartphone que não foi
a mente em 2007 mas 2007 foi um ano
muito significativo que foi o lançamento
do iphone o iphone foi um marco na
criação do smartphone exatamente esse
gráfico mostra para gente período de
2008 2009 2010 estrondoso crescimento na
venda de smartphones mas depois houve
uma desaceleração que é normal em
qualquer mercado e essa desaceleração
chegou ao seu ápice nós chegamos hoje
mas são dados de estatísticos né que
trazem o mercado ea produção de
smartphones no mundo e vários
pesquisadores inclusive isso to garner é
apresenta várias informações de que nós
chegamos a um ponto onde a curva agora
começa a descer 2014 nós estamos no
áudio garfo e dizia nossa 2014 foram
vendidos 1 bilhão de smartphones no
mundo já 2019 no primeiro trimestre olha
só a um decréscimo de 2,7 por cento na
av
o som do smartphone do mundo então isso
foi percebido por uma futurista não
treine em web no ano passado onde ela
falou sobre como 2018 marcou o início do
fim do smartphone e a partir dessa fala
dela eu comecei a pesquisar e acompanhar
e também concordando com ela eu resolvi
fazer essa apresentação e discutir um
pouco e aí vamos voltar um pouquinho
mais ao passado o que que veio antes do
smartphone bem antes de eu te alegro que
é lógico não foi a primeira forma de
comunicação mas a gente quer sair
tecnologia que depende de eletricidade e
já dentro do a visão mais contemporânea
depois veio o telefone que alguns de nós
ainda usamos né teimosamente usamos
mensagens sms usamos também alguns e nós
usamos e meio pelo primeiro celulares
trabalhava o primeiro pro blackberry não
existe mais porque ele só fazia isso só
mandar o e-mail também utilizamos a
world
e no celulares mais fora dele também e a
web só estourou mais ainda quando ela
passou a ser usada pelos dispositivos
móveis apesar dela já vai ser importante
estar importante nos computadores né no
celular explosão da web ela foi muito
mais rápido e finalmente o smartphone
ele veio chá parou tudo mudou tudo e
simplesmente capturou a nossa atenção e
sem várias pesquisas hoje sobre
produtividade que a gente perdeu para
ajudar ganhou produtividade está ficando
corcunda que está ficando míope você já
deve ter visto de diversas pesquisas
falando sobre o quanto smartphone afeta
nossa vida não só a nossa vida
tecnológica mas não sabia da física
fisiológica a vida até amorosa antes
destes né escute coisa antiga né quantos
divórcios e
e a partir dos smartphones nós tivemos
então o susto né de aplicativos tá tudo
aplications para tudo tudo é tem aqui
para tudo e na verdade se a gente for
olhar bem em todos esses apps tudo que
eles fazem nós fazíamos antes de existir
o smartphone mas trocávamos mensagens
nós pedimos comida pelo telefone a gente
leva o táxi por ele pelo telefone a
gente eu precisava mapa para poder
viajar em papel quando você vir ao
comprar um guia quatro rodas né para
poder fazer uma viagem conhecer as
estradas a gente tinha bailes para
conhecer as pessoas no sábado uma rede
social você ia é uma boate é tudo isso
já acontecia antes de outras formas
através de outros meios tecnológicos e o
smartphone veio para propiciar
determinadas facilidades com isso mas
nós já fazemos isso ou seja nós não
compramos um smartphone por causa do
smartphone nós compramos o smartphone
porque ele invadiu o seu espaço e ele
hoje faz praticamente
eu fazia antes pense bem porque que você
usa o seu smartphone é por causa dele
esse provavelmente não provavelmente é
porque você quer ou se entreter estudar
trabalhar vender alguma coisa arrumar
treta com alguém
e também os motivos né passatempo fazer
nada a gente faz para tudo mas é para
essas coisas que a gente usa smartphone
não por causa do smartphone tem uma
verdade talvez você possa fazer o mesmo
que você faz sem ele mas se eu quisesse
ele vou fazer com que o que que vai
substituir provavelmente alguns de vocês
aqui não vou perguntar de roupas algum
de vocês têm smartwatch vocês tem um
relógio que faz praticamente tudo que
você smartphone faz tem gente que que eu
faço com a saúde né que vai para
academia e usa o smart band faz corrida
eu a pulseira que mede seus pulsações né
sua saúde controla saúde melhor que você
mesmo também tem as smart tvs lá numa
loja e tenta comprar uma tv que não seja
smart chega em qualquer loja você quer
comprar uma tv você não quer amor tv
smart você não é só todas as
intervenções mais e o que é uma smart tv
esse é o smartphone para tela de 50
polegadas
é porque basicamente a mesma coisa não
dá para carregar no bolso mas ali tem
todas as características do smartphone e
você tá usando essas smart tv na sua
casa sem perceber que ela é um
smartphone com tela grandes machucar
todos os carros top eles têm centrais
multimídia para que tá na internet e
alguns carros elétricos inclusive eu já
te disse são tablet sobre rodas porque
na verdade a tecnologia toda a tava ali
na central multimídia e o resto é só
detalhe detalhes mecânicos e os carros
já estão conectados eles substituem
grande parte você conversa com o carro
óculos smart glasses o google glass não
deu muito certo mas tem outros aí que
estão surgindo com tecnologias mais
recentes headphones já tem headphone que
usa alexa do a da amazon e você conversa
com ele ele selecione com inteligência
artificial escolhe as músicas que você
vai ouvir você conversa discutir né não
sei se a discussão é sempre boa
dispositivos já eu ti que estão nos
eletrodomésticos que são também smart é
que estão
tô indo a sua necessidade de conectar o
smartphone alguma coisa você tem além
disso os dispositivos assistentes
pessoais digitais de todas essas grandes
empresas oferecem né que podem auxiliar
e você deixa o smartphone para usar
esses outros dispositivos os vestíveis
sus vai a bolsa deve tem uma série de
pois além dos óculos e das pulseiras
você tem palmilha tem chupeta smart
chupeta na questão dispositivos
conectados que podem captar capturar
informações dados é do ambiente martin
millôr se espelho de banheiro com todas
as tecnologias que você tem o seu
smartphone de manhã você já ver a
previsão do tempo o mapa com atenção
levar o trabalho é inclusive com as suas
redes sociais com todas as suas
notificações dos pelos manhã $1500 no
aliexpress você entrou lá tranquilo tá
disponível não é coisa de futuro não é
coisa de agora agora isso já futuro
superfícies smart paredes em que você
pode colocar dispositivos eletrônicos
inteligentes
e se você vai conversar com as paredes
quem diria que um dia nós iríamos
conversar com as paredes implantes
inteligentes não é isso que a gente já
tem plantas que cuidam da nossa saúde o
tempo todo a gente pode encontrar
notícias sobre eles no citar você
procurar se eu encontrar uma série de
implantes você melhora sua saúde melhor
a sua capacidade através desses
implantes ou seja nós estamos tirando
smart service nós mesmos será nós
estamos sim ou não bom texto tecnologia
propicia uma série de vantagens mas não
garante que essas vantagens vão
acontecer tudo isso smart vai depender
que nós nos tornemos smart também para
poder fazer bom uso dessas tecnologias e
o celular smartphone ele vai continuar
no seu bolso provavelmente sim ele vai
continuar porque você precisa dele assim
com muita gente ainda usa um relógio de
pulso mesmo tempo do celular
ah então provavelmente teremos o
smartphone do bolso mas ele não vai ter
mais toda essa atenção que a gente tem
hoje essa independência que você colocar
a mão no bolso celular não tiver lá
parece que tem um infarto onde eu deixei
o meu celular
e essa dependência vai diminuir por
causa dessa distribuição os serviços que
você usa hoje que estão exclusivamente
do seu celular estarão excluir
distribuídos e muitos outros serviços
muitos outros dispositivos e ele te
enfeitiçou enfeitiçou a gente não né a
gente fica meio assim esperando a
próxima lançamentos né e fica lá meio a
fissurado qual será a nova inovação lá
na é grande e a gente ficou bem fixado a
gente comer meio que a smartphone fruit
né eu é que gosta tanto dele que a gente
deposita tanta confiança que sem ele a
gente sente menos gente na verdade você
sair de casa você não consegue chamar um
uber não consegue conversar com ninguém
que não sabe o telefone de ninguém na
tua cabeça nem o seu provavelmente você
não sabe aí a você não consegue mandar
um e-mail não consegue whatsapp não
consegue nada a gente é mesmo gente ela
tá sem telefone então provavelmente isso
é um feitiço lá esse feitiço ele tende a
passar é porque na verdade o smartphone
ele foi um rolê
e são lembra que eu falei que o
futurismo é analisada passado transição
para o presente imaginar cenários
futuros você gente que sabem nós fazemos
todas essas coisas seu smartphone agora
nós fazemos com ele no futuro será que
nós precisamos dele será que ele é uma
necessidade realmente não sei tocando o
telefone de alberto
a ninguém
o meu ah desculpa isso eu eu tenho que
atender estas é
oh alô
nós precisamos conversar sobre uma coisa
só agora não dá tô aqui no tédio aqui
numa palestra não tem jeito a gente
falar agora então para hora a gente
conversa não é porque quer
ah ah não é
a discutir a relação agora não dá depois
a gente conversa em casa e lógico eu te
dou toda atenção mais linda meu carro é
meu parça eu já 50.000 km com ele eu vou
para outro lugar ouvindo música ele vai
me guiando não é ele é todo legal agora
é só um amigo qualquer os amigos esse
dia foi um dia que eu tava na sala e não
tava comigo e aí eu queria ver foi um
episódio só eu te juro foi só um
episódio e assim eu vejo de novo contigo
depois
boa noite
ah não fala assim ela é tão fina
[Música]
academia não academia já falei que não é
lugar para você lugar muito bruto você
muito delicada não é lugar para você na
academia
é inútil plantas vida já salvou aquela
pulseirinha que mede batimentos
cardíacos você tem que ir no médico
fazer exame que que é isso eu tava
ciumenta demais a não tem jeito toda
hora assistente pessoal a gente tem uma
relação és uma mas é uma relação que não
tem nada a ver nossa está sendo muito
dramática parece até que você tá
querendo terminar comigo então
bom então o quê
e aí
hum será que chegou a hora de dizer
adeus
com toda tecnologia ao nosso redor ela
evoluiu ela se transformou ela criou uma
sériede novidades mas o smartphone
também foi uma novidade que se
transformou o nome do tempo ele não
nasceu como ele é hoje ele pode se
transformar então na mesma forma quando
eu falo em a vida após smartphones lá
que nós vamos simplesmente deixar de
usá-lo há uma grande possibilidade do
smartphone se reinventar o smartphone
pode tentar acompanhar oferecer pois os
melhores que os outros dispositivos né
ser minha companhia trazer conselhos né
quando eu precisar você me o colt ser
meu guia né me levar para onde eu quero
ir o smartphone é pode me ajudar em
diversas soluções ainda que para
problemas que a gente nem sabe que a
gente tem então dizer que ele não tem
mais importância é um cheiro é na
verdade só o futuro vai dizer o que vai
acontecer em relação ao smartphone
é mas você não é futuro
oi tá me ouvindo ainda essa aqui já
tinha desligado não eu tenho uma
resposta para isso é que eu sou apenas
trem linha 1
bom então vamos esperar o futuro para
gente ver mas na verdade a gente não
precisa é só esperar responsivamente
porque na verdade é nós estamos todos
juntos nessa aventura as empresas as
grandes corporações não são elas que
definem exatamente o que a gente vai
querer o que a gente vai usar elas fazem
aquilo que a gente quer às vezes fazem o
que o mercado procura e como é que será
vida então após smartphone nós é que
vamos decidir através das nossas
escolhas daquilo que a gente quiser
comprar das nossas decisões de compra
dos nossos hábitos do que a gente gosta
e o que vai gostar de fazer
provavelmente serão coisas parecidas com
que a gente já fez no passado não muito
diferentes as nossas ações também não
serão muito diferentes ela só são
baseadas uma tecnologia diferente mas
nossos desejos as nossas ações nossos
atos não mudaram muito os nossos desejos
continuam os mesmos de antes do
smartphone e eu digo mais para sempre
executivo a gente tem que sonhar então o
futuro depende muito mais ea decepção
depende muito mais dos nossos sonhos do
que das
em ações essas decisões corporativas
sobre como é que vai ser isso aqui no
futuro meu nome é hélio vendo exposta e
eu sou um futurista frame
e aí